a lot of big 20/20 news to tell you
about including Bernie Sanders refusing
to back away from his love affair with
communist Cuba and will mini Mike
Bloomberg take another beating on the
debate stage tonight that's all coming
up later but first it's a president
Trump mixing it up with the liberal
media before leaving from India Donald
Trump hitting back against the failing
narrative that Russia's trying to help
him get reelected they never told me
anything about that and it was sort of a
strange thing that they went to Bernie
it was highly exaggerated
and frankly I think it's disgraceful and
I think it was leaks from the
Intelligence Committee I think probably
shift leaked it but Sir people within
that shift leaked it in my opinion and
he shouldn't be leaking things like that
that's a terrible thing to do
president Trump saving his best jobs
though for cNN's Jim Acosta first of all
I want no help from any country and I
haven't been given help from any country
and if you see what CNN here wonderful
Network said I guess they apologized in
a way for didn't they apologize for the
fact that they said certain things that
weren't fair tell me what was their
apology yesterday what did they say mr.
president I think our record on
delivering the truth is a lot better
than your some I'm saying let me tell
you about your record your record is so
bad you ought to be ashamed of yourself
yeah problem I'm not saying anything in
our probably and just when we thought
sore loser Hillary Clinton had gotten
over 2016 she's back warning about
Russia obviously we know the Russians
are continuing to try to choose our next
president like they chose our last
president and we just have to be more
vigilant and people have to pay
attention to trying to get the best
possible information and you know don't
believe everything you see on the
Internet that that is one of the
greatest challenges facing democracy
right now Dana she used to say well this
was my excuse and this was my excuse but
you know what I've lost and I take
responsibility that's out the window now
now she's just saying Russia chose Trump
yeah they it you could never actually
heal from an election and recover if you
don't if you're not honest with for the
reasons now she truly seems to believe
that Russia gave President Trump the
election there have been several
investigations at the highest levels of
government that have not proven that to
be so and yes it has does Russia want to
put some ads out there do they like to
medal is like probably yeah so that's
[ __ ] but I think that for President
Trump one of the ways to answer those
questions is to say I don't need their
help right I have a record I ran on this
record I don't need their help and we
like please if you're trying to help me
I don't need your help something like
that that would just be more like I said
yesterday derisive of Russia rather than
building them up to be something that
they're not Greg
Jim Acosta that means the the nerve to
say that CNN has a great track record on
telling the truth Wow I think I don't
know well CNN's ratings are in steep
decline and we see that because we see
the ratings every day and it is because
I believe they've lost the trust of the
American people by becoming the Weekly
World News four trumped arrangement it's
like everybody it's like if the if they
can link the back boy
to Trump they're gonna put it on the
cover and it's like they can't see
themselves so I'm gonna go on a little
bit of a rant against the media oh I'm
gonna try something new one if you don't
mind oh this is an epiphany
okay so we've watched the Fourth Estate
shattered
since 2016 embarrassment after
embarrassment right after III or you
we've been living decades kind of in
this sealed narrative of cultivated
stories that help make money for these
for these corporate companies but I
started thinking that it's not actually
about the events which are Russia
avenatti smollett covington Kavanagh
it's the fact that they all happened in
a concentrated time all insects in
succession used to be isolated like
things like Bork or Richard Jewell but
in the last four years we have seen so
many of them and I'm beginning to wonder
if it's because there are more of them
or because we have become so red pilled
that now
we finally see them for what they are
and now we question everything that we
didn't question before like we question
are we getting the right stuff about
Quran coronavirus do we are we getting
the real story and I think that's super
healthy that we now we do not trust this
and like one of trumps big achievements
it said he just put a scar across the
face of media that will never go away
and that everybody can see that scar for
the rest of their lives and I think it's
super important one thing on that
because there is some evidence that
Russia has been spreading misinformation
about the coronavirus online on purpose
to cause people fear and chaos and that
is some place where President Trump
could turn on us like knock it off like
enough of that and I think he's in a
position where he could do that Kati
maybe you're seeing all of these kind of
fake news scandals as Greg mentioned
happen a condensed period of time
because the media is so desperate they
have to manufacture this to get Trump
out of office as fast as possible and
because it's a 24-hour news cycle now
they have to keep generating rating
after rating point I saw CNN do a thing
yesterday that the Trump was gonna freak
out because there's no beef in India and
they had three reporters assigned to the
byline that was the headline like is the
president going to be able to survive
India on vegetarian meals that are
served to him at the state dinner I
think there are bigger issues to talk
about but you know what Russia loves
Russia loves that Americans are being
pitted against each other which is
exactly what they're always trying to do
and that they're talking about Russia
they're not interested necessarily in a
certain candidate whether it's Bernie
Sanders or Donald Trump or Hillary
Clinton they just want us fighting with
each other and when people like Adam
Schiff go through an entire impeachment
process and hours on the floor talking
about Russia whether it's the Moller
investigation dragging out whether it's
people on television making this claim
and the latest claim they had to walk
back with the intelligence now showing
that oh they're helping Bernie Sanders
win the primary now Russia doesn't care
they only care that we're fighting with
each other that Americans are at each
other's they're each other's throats and
that's exactly what they've been
successful at doing for the past three
years and the question is are people
going to continue to allow them to do
that we're so concerned about Russian
meddling why don't we stop giving them
so much credit for doing something that
they're not
actually in control of yeah they're
getting free media it's a but just if
you use common sense wouldn't you just
think that maybe Putin would want Bernie
since Bernie wants to slash defense
spending he wants to get rid of space
for us wait a second wait a second I
think I mean this has been so twisted
here at this table I don't even know
where to start but let me just say over
the trailer yeah Hillary Clinton did not
go off about the Russians helping Donald
Trump what she said was the Russians
continue to interfere continue to spread
misinformation election let me just say
they not only hacked
Hillary Clinton if you recall but then
used it against her campaign they
weaponized the information in such a way
that drove mainstream media to covered
as if it was news and weather with the
dossier add this to the American people
and then you say oh what is Hillary
Clinton which was to publish wiki we
know they certainly did not and I way
that they do that they went after so
many other things including by the way
my phone number so I'm gonna tell you
something on well it's very real so if
Hillary Clinton on they re about if
Hillary Clinton says and before you
distort it Hillary Clinton says you know
what you have to be careful about what
you read on the Internet and it's
disinformation I think we should say
Gooding I know you don't like Hillary
Clinton but that's the truth if you're
listening find one you got you got to
understand that Trump yeah I will take
Trump at his word that he wasn't told
about Russian interfering to help him
because remember I think it was one of
his Chiefs of staff's told Kristin
Kristin Nielsen when she was over at
Homeland Security don't mention anything
about Russia to Trump it upsets him so
maybe people don't want to tell him but
if that's the case let's also take it at
faith because it's also true that Russia
interfered in 16 and everybody who has
investigated from the top levels of
government to people who are online say
the bots and the Russians continued
interfere
push this story for four years you have
to ignore the biggest foreign
interference story of all which is a
damn dossier you guys sit and talk about
are you talking about little BOTS nice
use the dossier let me just say
seriously and not be taken by tomato the
media every night is the meeting
immediate role of that story trump uses
the internet just like the rush in the
website oh yeah what are you talking
about someone here today I'm talking
about oh my or as wise as opposed to MIT
research you're killing yourself
whoa you know we're telling Donald Trump
is killing America oh well you just got
back from Disney World
you should walk around with a try I
don't think of a vacation of relax all
right